Have you ever been talking out loud and
while you're talking somebody says,
"Well, you know what I think is?" And
they just run right over you. What's the
first thing you think? You go, "Oh,
okay. I guess I'll stop talking now."
All of a sudden, they are controlling
the floor. Now they're dominating the
conversation and you really don't have
another window and you feel defeated.
What do you do when somebody is talking
over you? Well, there's a wrong way to
go about it and a right way to go about
it and I'm going to teach you both. Now,
if you listen to the rest of this
podcast, you are going to learn exactly
how to stop it when somebody tries to
dominate the conversation. You ready?
The wrong way to go about this is when
you start to yell and start to try and
get more attention to you. Somebody
starts interrupting you and the first
thing you say is, "Oh, excuse me. Am I
interrupting you?" Or, "Oh, is the end
of my sentence interrupt the beginning
of yours?" That kind of trying to be
cute language. That never works. Let me
tell you why it doesn't work. Because it
makes you look desperate. So whenever
somebody is dominating the conversation
and interrupts you, the worst thing you
can try and do is trying to take it back
from them when you try to out attention
them. That never works. It always puts
you in the weaker position. Why? Because
it looks like you're grasping for
control. That is the wrong way to go
about it. Instead, this is what I want
you to do when somebody tries to
dominate the conversation and talk over
you. You ready? Number one, I want you
to continue talking exactly as you were.
Keep the same volume, keep the same
tempo, keep the same pace, keep talking
just like you were. Do not stop. So when
everybody whenever that person at the
board meeting and wherever you are, they
start to try and catch in trying to talk
over you. Oh, I think what about and
they and they try and talk over you.
keep talking exactly where you are. This
works because it shows a discrepancy
between your very even kill controlled.
I'm going to continue talking no matter
what you say, even if you interrupt me.
I am planted. I am grounded. I do not
care what you say. Whenever you keep
that same plane and they are just yeah,
barking way up here trying to get your
attention, trying to get everybody
else's attention, it shows that
discrepancy of you being very controlled
and them trying to grasp for control.
They're trying to get that attention
from everybody else while you are the
one staying calm and controlled. So
number one is continue to talk. Don't
stop talking. All right. Number two,
what I want you to do is resist the
temptation to raise your voice.
We always want to try and out talk the
other person whenever somebody starts
raising their voice. It's very natural.
It's very easy for us because we're
trying to kind of uh jump over them.
We're trying to It's like playing
checkers. You want to kind of jump over
them. You want to get on top of the
conversation. You want to dominate it in
some way. Anytime you do that, all it
does is escalate them to talk even more.
That's how shouting matches happen. Like
if you watch the news and you see the
talking heads on the news and the people
that are just fighting just arguing to
argue or if you watch like sports
commentary maybe on ESPN or something
and and you hear people taking two
different positions and somebody's
interrupting the other and somebody's
interrupting the other and they just
start kind of yelling back and forth.
Who's listening? Nobody. What do you do?
You change a channel. Nobody's learning
anything. Nobody can get anything from
that because it's just a power grab for
attention. So you're going to resist
that. All right. you're going to resist
that by continuing to keep your volume
exactly as it is. Why? Again, it shows
that discrepancy. That's what you want.
Number three, we're just swinging right
at it today. We're going we're going
straight for the throat. Anytime that
that person is trying to
dominate the conversation or interrupt
or continue talking and you don't feel
like you have a window, let's say we're
at a a board meeting and they're just
continue to talk and you don't feel like
you have a window into it. Here's the
key. use their name. People love to hear
their name. There's no sweeter sound
than the sound of their own name. So, if
they're talking and they're droning on
and they've kind of taken away the
conversation and gone on with their own
voice and with their own subject and
they think what they're saying is the
most important thing, I want you to use
their name. Use their name. So, let's
say it's me. Let's me I'm the big bad
guy right now and I am I just taken over
the conversation. you're talking to me
and I go, well, you know what I think is
you you ought to go, you know what you
should do? And I just start going on
away in my own views, opinions, and I'm
talking to an audience of one. If you
need to get my attention, what I want
you to say is, Jefferson,
that'll pop my head quick. Jefferson,
it's not raising your voice. You're not
saying it angry. You're not saying it
too um tender, almost too hesitant.
You're going to say it strong. You're
going to say it clear. Jefferson, if I
keep talking, say it again. Jefferson,
even if you need to raise the volume a
little bit, it's going to get my
attention. It's going to get the other
person's attention. They are going to
stop because they hear their name.
That's where that's the window. You've
now created the window into that
conversation where I want you to use the
phrase talk over.
Say something like, "It's not helpful
when you talk over me." Or, "I feel like
you're talking over me." Or, "I can't
hear you when you talk over me." I say
the very similar thing when somebody's
interrupting you, which in in this case
is very related. I can't hear you when
you talk over me.
This episode is also brought to you by
Element. Element makes hydrating easy,
simple, and clean. [music] If you're
like me, you're always on the go,
especially when I'm traveling. I need to
do better about hydrating, especially in
and out of airports. But it's not all
that fun sometimes to just drink a
bottle of water. So, I use a little
packet of Element. I've been using it
for several months now, and I really
like it. My favorite flavor is lemonade
salt. I pour it right in. It's like
lemon lime. It's tangy, it's sweet, and
it always gets the job done. I like it
because there's no added dyes, there's
no added sugars, just good, clean
electrolytes. Element is for people on a
mission. Whether you're a parent, an
athlete, a business leader, and for all
of my listeners, you get a free sample
pack for every order that you get. So, a
free sample pack with every order. You
can go to drinklnt.com/jfferson
and try it risk-f free. That's
drinklnt/jfferson
and try it riskfree. Anytime you're
using that phrase talk over, it's cluing
them into exactly what they're doing.
Sometimes people don't understand what
they're doing. They don't realize what
they're doing it. Maybe it's not on
purpose, but that's beside the point
that the the fact is they're doing it.
So you have to take action. You can't
just be quiet and let them continue to
talk and and you and you feel less. Then
you feel more dismissed. That kind of
behavior is something that you need to
catch immediately. You can't let it keep
going on. Why? Because you're otherwise
establishing a pattern of how they can
treat you, how they can talk to you,
that it's just a given that your opinion
does not matter as much as theirs. But
if you catch it, Jefferson,
I can't hear you when you talk over me.
It's not helpful for you to talk over
me. Jefferson, are you interested in my
thoughts or do you want to talk over me?
It depends how direct you need to be. I
You're the one who knows the personality
of the person that you're dealing with.
But that is exactly how I want you to
handle when somebody is talking over
you. I had something very similar when I
was a young associate at a law firm.
There was another associate of mine and
she had great ideas but she never felt
like she could really share them in the
meetings that we'd have and we'd have
other associate meetings. There would be
about 8 to 10 of us and she didn't feel
like she could really use her voice that
way. She was much more hesitant,
but still she had wonderful ideas. And
there are times where I would kind of
focus the conversation to tee it up so
she could talk. But at the same time, I
didn't always want to be the crutch that
goes, "Oh, she let me help guide the
conversation to her." So, I talked to
her about it. Said, "This is what I want
you to do." The next time David
starts to bounce over onto your
conversation. I want you to use his name
and watch what happens. Sure enough,
while she's given an idea of what she
thinks we should try and do for the
upcoming year, David immediately kind of
goes on the attack. You ever had
somebody who
in a meeting, specifically in a group,
that just wants to always feel like they
can go right for you. They can go right
for you every time. That for some reason
you're you're scapegoat. For some
reason, you're the outlet for them that
they as soon as you start talking, boom,
there they go. something about it
triggers you, triggers them. It was the
same way in this relationship. And so
she started talking. Boom. David goes
in. And first thing she had said, she
did was continue to talk exactly how she
was. What did it do? It didn't make her
look weak. It made him look weak because
looked like he was trying to get in in
the conversation and she was totally
ignoring it. Who we listened to? We
started listening to her, not him.
because it showed everybody in the room
what he was doing was not acceptable as
a group, as a community. He was now
making himself kind of as the outsider.
What she did next as he continues to
talk is she used his name. She used his
name and he snapped to attention. David,
you're talking over me. That's all she
said. You know what he did? Immediately
apologized. Why? Because he's looking
around and seeing everybody kind of
agrees. Nobody was fighting. Nobody was
sticking up for him. He's like, "Oh,
I'm, you know, I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Go
ahead." Never again did he do that. So,
I want you to really think about this.
The next time that somebody is trying to
dominate a conversation, some somebody's
trying to speak over you, number one,
what I want you to do is to continue to
talk. Two, resist the temptation to
raise your voice to outtalk them because
that's a weaker position ultimately.
Three, what I want to make sure that you
do is realize the power of somebody's
name. So, if they keep on talking, use
their name. It is going to snap their
attention. It's going to make them stop
because they need to hear what comes
after their name, why you're using the
sweet sound of their name. That's your
window to be able to communicate exactly
what's happening into action. All right,
sound good. I love this kind of stuff.
It's awesome. Quick, to the point. You
can do it. I know that you can. If you
feel like you lose control in
conversation more than you keep it, this
episode is for you. I'm making this
specifically for you. What I'm going to
teach you if you listen to this episode
is exactly how to make sure that that
shift of power returns back to you. I'm
going to make it short. I'm going to
make it sweet. And it's going to work.
You ready? Controlling conversation is a
funny thing. You don't know how to
describe it, but you know when you don't
have it. You know when you could get it.
It's in that time that the usually in
the silence of the conversation that as
things are going, momentum starts to
shift the other way, starts to swing the
other way and it feels like everything
around you is kind of dissolving.
Think of a time most recently in your
life where you felt the power dynamic
shift. Maybe it's somebody who's a
superior. Maybe it's somebody who
intimidates you. Maybe it's somebody you
don't like. Or maybe it's somebody you
love and it still feels like you don't
have something inside of you that's able
to keep what's yours. And instead you
feel like you're giving it all away,
your needs, your wants, your your power,
your control, whatever it is, your
truth. This episode is going to teach
you exactly what to do. So, how do we do
that? Number one, you're going to use
questions
that force a reset in the conversation.
Now, what do I mean by that? Think of
like your laptop or your phone. You you
have a a button typically that has like
a forced reset. It doesn't matter what's
happening. Maybe you're on your phone
and it it freezes or your laptop and it
freezes. What do you have to do? You
have to kind of like hold the power
button down until it eventually what?
Shuts off and then [snorts] you're able
to click it again and force restart it.
It's not doing it on its own. You are
having to inject something into it.
That's what these questions do. These
are intelligent questions. These are not
just the basic ones. These are questions
that call for reflection in the
conversation that make people think. And
that alone is going to stop the
momentum,
stop the shift, momentum, the power
that's going away from you and bring
that control back to you in a way or at
least the very least level the playing
field. You said, Jefferson, what do
these questions sound like? I'm going to
tell you. These are questions that sound
like, are you against us talking at a
normal tone? Are you against us talking
about this calmly?
Are you against us talking about this
openly?
Is it unreasonable for me to ask you to
lower your voice? Is it unreasonable for
me to assume that what I tell you can be
kept in confidence?
Or maybe it's I need to know where we're
going in this conversation. Can you help
explain to me where we're going in this
conversation? Where is this conversation
going?
So, these are three key words that I
really picked up on that I'm I'm wanting
you to pick up on is one, we are using
the the natural mind to think in the
negatives. Meaning, if somebody asked
you to do something, typically you want
to say no. Think of when you're kids. I
if I ask my daughter when she was two to
go do something, the first thing she'd
say is no. We have the same exact thing.
It doesn't go away. We just have
different filters as we age. Well, if I
were to say, "Are you against us talking
about this calmly?"
The first thing they're going to want to
respond with is no.
Are you against? No, I'm not against
that. Then they will naturally lower it.
No. Who's going to say yes, I'm against
talking calmly? So, you use that to your
advantage. It makes them think it's If I
If I'm going to say, "Are you are you
against us talking about this in a way
that's helpful?" You hear how it makes
you almost have to work through it
backwards? It takes some time even
though it sounds simple for somebody to
hear it. Reverse engineer it. That's the
time frame that you want. All right,
that's levels the playing field. That's
the forced reset. That moment where
people have to think and you get to now
ask a question and they are now
acquiescing to what you've asked for. Is
it unreasonable? Most people will again
say no to things. If I were to say, is
it reasonable to ask you to stop
yelling? You know what's going to
happen? They're going to say no. It's
not reasonable. You You know how upset I
am right now? But if I were to say, "Is
it unreasonable for me to ask you to
lower your voice?"
They're not going to say yes, it is.
They'll most likely say no. Why? Because
no is easier to say. In that moment
where they reverse engineer the
question, that's the shift of momentum.
I need you to tell me where we're going
in this conversation. Help me understand
where we're going. It's easy. It's it's
the I am wanting to know where's the
deadline. Where's the the finish line?
Not the deadline, the finish line. Where
do we go there? All that's doing is
making them think, hey, what am I
talking about this for? What am I
talking about this for? It's it's
jumping to that end. You are creating
that moment where they have to pause.
They respond to your question, which
levels the playing field because that
time stops the momentum. It is like
icing the kicker in football. If you
watch American football, you know that a
lot of times they will if if or even in
basketball, lots of different sports
when things are going a team's way and
especially in basketball and somebody is
they're scoring a lot, the other team
will typically call a timeout. Let's
stop the momentum. They're they're
getting too much going on. That's
exactly what these questions do. Exactly
what these questions do. And it gives
you the control back in the
conversation. Number two, aside from
intelligent questions that are making
them stop, what I want you to think of
is times where you can use phrases that
are going to call moments of more
reflection for the other person.
Why? Because it is giving you that
control back. There's not a statement I
can tell you that's going to just force
the control there. Questions do it.
Questions do it. My favorite, and if you
listen to this podcast, you know, is the
phrase, "Did you mean?" Did you mean for
that to sound dismissive? Did you mean
for that to sound a little manipulative?
Did you mean for that to embarrass me or
offend me? The did you mean questions,
what they do is they put a big spotlight
on the other person's behavior and it
makes them have to think about what
their motive was. What was my intent in
asking this? What was my motive in
asking this? And usually if it's a a
truly negative motive like did you say
that to embarrass me? It forces them to
now like they they feel angst. They they
they don't like that they got heartburn.
Now they got called out. They got called
out. And now what they have to do is
shift it back. They have to uh stop.
They have to hedge. They have to put on
the brakes and realize, whoa, whoa,
whoa. I'm I'm getting called out right
here. I don't like that. I'm going to
start looking bad. I don't want that.
And so they'll they'll turn that
trajectory. And what they do is they
lower and now you're more balanced in
the conversations. Did you mean number
three? One of my favorite things to do
in conversations, particularly when it
feels like somebody else is trying to
take control in the conversation, I will
ask the question, are we on equal
footing?
It could be something very similar to
that. Is this a conversation where we're
balanced?
I talk about things that are up and
down. I want to make sure that we're
walking side by side. And usually I'll
ask that question. Are we walking side
by side right now? I want to make sure
I'm walking alongside you in this
conversation. Whenever you're using
words that call balance, even the
imagery of balanced,
are we are we side by side here? Are we
balanced? Are we on the same plane? Are
we on the same footing? You can think of
a thousand other ways to say it. What
they do, these phrases, these questions
that make the other person kind of slow
down. They make them slow down in the
conversation. That's what you want. And
that's what's going to return the
control back to you. There's nothing you
can say that's going to say, "Hey, I
want control back in this conversation."
That's not going to happen. If it's a
statement, what it does is it makes you
look like you are
uh vain. It makes you look like you're
aggressive. It makes you look like you
are desperate. It makes you desperate is
the best word for it. It It makes you
look like you're already lost it. All
right? Makes you look like you've
already lost it. Before we keep going, I
want to take a second to tell you about
monarch money. Have you ever tried to
keep track of all your finances in your
head? It's not easy, right? A couple of
checking accounts over here, a credit
card, maybe a retirement fund that you
swore that you check on last spring,
maybe some change under the couch,
whatever. Until suddenly, it feels like
everything that has to do about money is
just some big cloud, some big jigsaw
puzzle, and you've lost the pieces and
all of a sudden there is that fear and
concern. That's natural. That's normal.
That's where Monarch comes in to help
you. It pulls everything together. All
your accounts, your savings, your
investments, even your spending, even
your spending, and shows it all in one
place. A simple dashboard. No
spreadsheets, uh, no guessing. Just one
big place that makes your money make
sense. Puts you in control rather than
feeling like everything else is
controlling you without you having to
spend hours and hours managing it. If
you've been putting this stuff off,
Monarch makes it easy. You'll see what's
working, what's not working, and how to
get there when you want to go faster.
Don't let financial opportunity slip
through the cracks. Use code
Jefferson.com
in your browser for half off your first
year. That's 50% off your first year at
monarch.com. Use the code Jefferson. And
now, let's get back to that episode. One
of the best of the ways I I can think of
rather than trying to grasp for that
attention.
Control is a is also found in the
silence.
So many times in conversation,
the most powerful move you can make is
no move at all. Not saying anything. If
you want to return conversational power
back to you, often silence
and pauses are the best thing that's
going to do that. Pauses.
If you if somebody else is on a roll,
you can call your own timeout. If they
are being and when I say on a roll,
maybe they are being way too aggressive
with you. Then what you say is I need to
come back to this conversation when I'm
in a better place.
I'll come back to this conversation when
I'm ready. I can tell I'm not in a good
I'm not myself right now. I can tell I'm
not ready for this conversation. This is
not a conversation that I need to be in
right now.
Pause it. time it. Why did I say that?
Say it like that. Take a timeout. Pause
the conversation. And what you do is now
the nerves settle. What happens is
you're able to now look like you're the
one that's in control of the
conversation because you're not
responding emotionally. You're not
saying things you don't mean. You're not
trying to say the yeah, buts. But but
what about you're not trying to throw
daggers and add these little paper cuts
to the conversation that don't do
anything. Control is also very much
found in the silence and taking breaks
and what's that? That that is you
calling your shot of when and you when
you will not have conversation.
Those three tips right there alone, see
I told you short and sweet rolled right
into it. That's exactly what's going to
help you the next time you feel like
you're losing power in a conversation.
So, what do we talk about? Number one,
using intelligent questions. Are you
against? Is it unreasonable? Show me
where we're going. Anything related to
that, using the the negatives. That's
going to get somebody to have to think
more reflectively about the conversation
and stop the momentum. Two, we're going
to use questions that talk about the
intent and motive. That's going to again
reflect that and make them pause. Three,
largely I want to go right into that.
Silence. That's number three. Silence is
so often the very thing that will stop
the m momentum, bring control back
because you are choosing your words when
you want them and what you want to say.
That's how you keep control. The key to
handling conflict is not what you say,
it is what you observe. In today's
episode, I'm going to teach you exactly
what I teach every single one of my
legal clients. So, if you've ever
wondered what's it like to be a legal
client of Jefferson, well, today is your
chance to do that. Today's the lucky
day. We're going to dive into how do you
handle high stress conflict situations
and operate at a different level that
you did not know was possible. When we
talk about difficult, high stress
conflict. I'm I'm talking about not just
a little bitty everyday arguments. I'm
talking about something that's on your
plate that's coming up right now and you
go, Jefferson, I don't know how to
handle this. I I don't know what to do.
I I'm afraid I'm going to shut down. I'm
afraid I'm going to get nervous. I'm
going to tell you exactly what I tell
every single one of my clients. You
ready? Number one, it is not what you
say. It is not anything to do with your
mouth. It has everything to do with your
nervous system. And the key here is
instead of absorbing,
you're observing. I'm going to say it
again. Instead of absorbing,
you're observing. If you want to handle
conflict at a different level of
consciousness that you did not know you
could handle it, it is going to be the
key of not absorbing what they say but
observing what they say. All right, say
it with me. Say it with me wherever you
are. It's not absorbing, it's observing.
All right, what does that mean? I want
you to think, this is just coming to me
right now. I want you to think you're in
the grocery store and you have your your
cart with you and you're going through
and you or maybe maybe you're somebody
who likes a bag, you know, you you you
have a I'm I'm all for environmentally
friendly stuff, too, though it's hard
here in Texas. And you have your cart
and [clears throat] you just start
putting things on the shelf or grabbing
things off the shelf and putting it in
your basket that you you don't even
want, right? You don't even want the
things just start to come in. You're
like, "Yeah, you know what? I'm going to
take their belittling opinion of me. I'm
going to put it in my cart. You know,
I'm going to take their side eye, put it
in my cart. I'm going to take that that
disrespectful tone and put that in my
cart. And you just keep going all the
way through aisle by aisle. And then you
go to check out, which is actually a
very good word for this. Yeah. You you
you mentally check out. And you know
what checks in? Your nervous system,
your emotions, and they just flood you
in that moment. And and in in that point
in time, you have absorbed. You have
taken on so many things that there's
nothing left for you. You're not
observing. You're not seeing what's
happening. You're just in it. You're
just in it. And you are helpless to it.
It is no longer you who controls the
emotions. The emotions are now
controlling you. And there's no telling
what you're going to say. There's no
there's no nobody can guess what's going
to come out of your mouth or what's
going to happen because you're not
there. You are checked out. So, when I
tell my clients, hey, when you're in the
chair and somebody is the other attorney
is asking you questions, there's going
to be a time where all of a sudden
you're tempted to go in it to to to go
down the spiral and look inside and look
at yourself and feel emotions and get
heated because you're going to start
taking things personally. You're going
to start absorbing what they're saying.
No, no, no, no. If you want to handle
this the right way, the proper way in
conflict, you have to start observing.
What does that mean? That means you're
going to approach the conversation at a
different level of consciousness that
you have before. That means instead of
going, "How how could you say that to
me? Oh my gosh, I'm" and you start
holding your breath and you start
getting flustered and you get nervous or
maybe you tear up. is because you're not
seeing it as, huh, I wonder why he's
asking me this. I wonder why she's
saying that. I wonder where they're
going with this. Look for the intent
behind the words.
The intent behind the words. When you
are observing what's happening in some
sense, being an attached observer. I've
said this before where you it's like you
are sitting in a movie theater with your
popcorn and you're watching the
conversation take place. And that puts
you in a different perspective of
looking at the person who's talking to
you and thinking, I wonder why that
character is saying this. I wonder what
the plot is. I wonder what the narrative
is. I I wonder what scene is coming up
next. And you see how when you look at
it that way, you have full control.
You're now the director, the producer,
the screenwriter of exactly what happens
next. And then it's just action. And
you're able to be in the state of mind
of, hey, I'm observing the conversation.
And from there, that gives you a chance
to let your body regulate because you're
not in it. You are seeing it. You're
seeing the conversation. Number two,
what I teach every one of my clients is
something that's at the forefront of my
book. The next conversation, argue less,
talk more. And rule number one when I
say say it with control, and that is let
your breath
>> [snorts]
>> be the first word that you say.
I've been talking a little fast here in
this podcast, which is unlike me. I
think I'll tell you why. I drink too
much coffee this morning. Too much
coffee. Admittedly, usually I talk
pretty slow. All right. Can you hear how
just the way I'm talking now and how I'm
slowing down just a little bit might in
a micro
percentage also slow you down a little
bit. Maybe you know the neural activity
in your brain is starting to slow down
just a little bit. Maybe you feel a
little bit more relaxed at me speaking a
little more slowly. When I put
a breath before my words,
it is making sure that I am regulating
myself. And even more importantly, I am
showing you
I am showing you that I am regulated,
that I am in control. And what I'm about
to say, I've chosen.
I've chosen those words.
It makes a very big difference. So, when
I teach my clients, hey, don't get
wrapped up. Don't try and step on
somebody's question. Don't try to
interrupt them. Let them get it out and
then you observe the question. Observe
the the interaction. Take a breath
and then choose what you want to say.
You are in complete control of the pace
of any conversation. Nobody can make you
say anything you don't want to say and
nobody can make you say it at a time you
don't want to say it. That choice is
yours. That choice is yours. And I
cannot tell you how many clients I have
seen come to find accept and grow in
their own power and their own sense of
value and worth of wow I I get to choose
if I say anything. And you know what? If
I want to wait 30 seconds before I say
something, I can do that.
It's it is a freeing feeling to know,
you know, I'm going to think about this.
Let me chew on this question for a
second.
Just that alone, the ability to say that
says, "Oh, no, no. I'm I'm operating at
a different level you don't know about.
No, I'm I'm not who you thought I was. I
know exactly what I'm doing. I'm going
to choose my words and I'm going to show
you that what I'm about to say is
something that I absolutely mean and I'm
saying with intention. All right? Can
you feel the difference? Say, what kind
of breath are we talking about? I've run
through this breath before. It's always
good to do it because it's something
that is good for me, too. Is a
conversational breath. And what it does,
it's based on a physiological sigh,
which is a double
Oh, that kind of sounded weird. Double
inhalation.
double inhalation. So, you're breathing,
you're inhaling twice. All right? So,
ready with me? We're going to breathe
through your nose. Wherever you are,
just do it. Don't worry about it. People
might look at you. Don't worry. Ready?
We're going to breathe in through your
nose about two to three seconds.
One more at the top [snorts]
and then let out through your nose.
My guess is you're starting to come down
a little bit. Maybe your shoulders
relaxed a little bit. is the feeling
that mimics a sigh. When you use that
kind of breath, and I promise you, you
continue to do it while I'm talking
right now. You'll see that you get
really good at it. You can do it any
time. The most crucial part for me is
when I teach my clients to do it is
before they answer the question. Just
take two seconds or one second. What we
like to say here in the South is just
say one Mississippi. In other words, in
in your head, you're going to go
Mississippi.
like well you can use your own name if
you have a long name you know just
whatever it is it's it's to get you in
the mindset of taking a beat a moment
take that breath and choose what you
want to say it is always going to be
better all right let's be honest there
are people out there right now you don't
like they come to mind immediately and
the truth is there are also other people
that don't really like you but how do
you communicate with these people when
you have to be with them at work or
around in the house or in your
community. How do you talk to them? This
episode is all about how to talk to
somebody who doesn't like you. And I'm
not exempt from this, by the way, the
whole people not liking you thing. There
are people that I can think right now
come to mind that I don't like. And I
know that there are people listening,
maybe probably not listening, but maybe
some that don't like me. And that's
okay. That's normal because we're not
meant to be for everybody, right? There
are people in your life that if you were
for everybody, you're kind of probably
doing something wrong. There's going to
be somebody who isn't a fan of what
you're doing. That's that's kind of a
good sign in my in my world. If somebody
is not always a fan of what you're doing
because it means that you're you're on
the right track, you're pushing, you're
persevering, not everybody has to agree
with what you're doing. That's my that's
my point. How do you handle it? How do
you handle it? How do you talk to
somebody who doesn't like you or you
don't like them? You ready? Number one,
treat them like they like you. Talk to
them like they like you. I know that
sounds counterintuitive. That's the
point. There are people that when you
come into the room and you know good and
well they don't like you, what they're
looking for is even more reasons not to
like you. But when you start treating
them just as normal as can be, like
nothing ever happened in the past, it's
going to not only bother them, which is
pretty cool, it's it's also going to
kind of go, "Huh, wait, this is not this
is not what I thought." And sometimes
they'll actually feel bad that they even
ever had the impression that they didn't
like you. It could work either way. The
point is, don't give someone a reason to
not like you because that that pulls
down your integrity. You be you.
is my point. You be you. Don't worry
about if they like you or don't like
you. So, treat them in conversation just
as pleasant as I'm talking to you. Now,
big disclaimer here. You ready? Big
disclaimer. This is not about being
fake. What I'm not telling you is to be
fake and pretend that everything's fine.
That's not it. I can be cordial with
you. I can be kind. I can be polite. I
can be respectful without ever having to
do anything with whether I like this
person, prefer this person, I'm a fan of
this person or not. You just be you,
right? That's all that is. So, if
somebody's acting like they don't like
you, treat them even more so like they
like you. Don't worry about what they're
doing. You concentrate on what you're
doing. Right? And here's the key. Here's
the key takeaway, and this is probably
one of my favorite points, is if they
don't like you, they're not that
important. Most likely, they're not that
important. If they genuinely don't like
you, they're not that important. Why?
Because they don't that means they don't
know you well enough, they're not in a
place where they can really hold any
kind of judgment of you, that's that's
really going to weigh on you. So, what
do you do? Number one, treat them like
they like you. What happens when you're
around somebody and you know you don't
really like them and they don't really
like you and you decide to kind of shift
or sherk them off or act a certain way.
All it does is double down on their
decision not to like you. All it does is
in their mind they're going, "Oh, I knew
I didn't like this person." because
they're they're all they're doing is
looking for ways to justify, validate,
imprint that impression in their mind of
that they don't like you. So when you
turn the tables and you act pleasant,
respectful,
you be you, that messes with their head
and they go, "Huh, okay, maybe that
wasn't the the re the right impression
that I was supposed to have. Maybe that
wasn't the right impression I was
supposed to have." Number two, if you
can't do that, if you go, "No,
Jefferson, look, I like you, man, but
no, I'm not I'm not doing that." Here's
what I want you to do. Go neutral. Just
go flat. That means I want you to use
neutral statements. When you're talking
to them, and you don't want the
conversation to go anywhere, use words
that are stop to the conversation that
you can't do anything with. These are
neutral words like got it, noted,
understood, yep, interesting words that
nobody can you can't continue to take
those words and go anywhere. So stay
neutral in the conversation. If if you
really can't be at a place where you can
be pleasant around this person, if you
if you're really deciding that you're
just going to go sour, which I get it,
we're we're we're normal and human. At
least try to go neutral where there's
nothing negative you're going to be
doing. There's nothing positive you're
going to be doing. So use statements
that keep the conversation neutral.
You're not inflaming anything. You are
going to use statements that really
can't do anything with. So if they talk
to you, instead of having this attitude
or making things worse or just
confirming their belief for whatever
reason that they don't like you or you
don't like them, it's got it, noted.
Thank you. Understood. Appreciate it.
You see how I'm not even using full
sentences. It's not I appreciate that.
It's appreciate it. Cool. Using very
shortened versions that are very
neutral, very flat. and nobody can do
anything with them. Now, before we keep
going, I want to take a second to tell
you about Momentus. Momentus is a
sponsor of this podcast because I use
their stuff. It's a supplement company.
About a year ago, I decided to really
care about what I'm putting in my body.
I'm a father. I'm now an author. I'm a
speaker. I'm an attorney. I wear a lot
of hats. And that means I need to go,
hey, wait a second. How is my health?
And so when I think of what I'm not
getting in my diet, I know that Momentus
helps me with that. I take I take a lot
of their products long before they ever
sponsored this podcast. They have a
whole sleep stack that helps me sleep
better. I have things like their
creatine, their proteins, their omega-3s
to help me with my workouts. I have mag
their magnesium, which is very big and
it's helped me even with um any stress
and anxiety. So it's it's good stuff.
And I know like you I don't have time to
research every little supplement.
Momentus makes it easy. Easy to order.
Their products are clean. It's
effective. And it's trustworthy. Go to
livemus.com.
Use the code jeff Jefferson and get up
to 35% off your first subscription.
That's live momentous.com.
Use the code Jefferson and get up to 35%
off your first subscription. Momentous.
When your moment matters, make it count.
And now back to the episode. Number
three,
keep the sarcasm, the snarkiness at
home. All right? Instead, stick to
facts. If it's somebody who's does not
like you, instead of reinforcing and
embolding that, emboldening that
decision of them, I think that's a word,
emboldening. Let's say it is. You get my
point. Instead of that, just stick to
facts. Here's what I mean. Let's say
you're in an office uh at a meeting and
somebody comes in and you know you don't
really like them, they don't really like
you. And they ask a question and they're
like, "What did I miss?" And you say,
"Well, I mean, if you were here, you
would know that sarcasm that does
nothing but to make you feel better and
it's going to make them dislike you even
more."
Where you come in and you go, "Well, I
mean, it would be nice if somebody did."
or well, if you were around or if you
really cared, you'd find out these
passive aggressive comments. Stop that.
So, just empty out the passive
aggressive comments. They don't do
anything. I know in that moment because
you kind of want to jab them, right? You
want to go, "Yeah, I know you don't like
me, so let me just poke you in the aisle
with this stick."
Don't Don't do that. All right? Keep
that home. Instead, just stick to facts.
facts as reasons why you're here and why
you're going to leave at some certain
future. So, let's say instead if they
ask for the time, you're just going to
give the time. Don't give the
snarkiness. If you come in, say, "I'm
here to discuss this or I need to talk
to you about why." There's not a Okay,
well, I I got to talk to you and I I
guess um Okay, I guess we're doing this.
Um so, here's the thing.
Get rid of all that. Get rid of all of
it.
it's not serving you. It's not making
you a better person. Instead, just stick
neutral to the facts. There's so much in
this because it's natural for us to not
like people. Again, if they don't like
you, they're not that important. And
that's okay. And I I can get down with
the idea of if you don't have somebody
who's rooting against you, it means
you're not going towards something
important enough. Like if you don't have
if if if
you're not chasing something, maybe it's
a business that you're building, maybe
it's a content that you're trying to
create, if you have people that are the
naysayers, the people that are uh
doubting you, then typically it means in
my mind, your goals aren't big enough.
Yeah. You need to reach for these goals
that are so big and you feel like you're
doing something so important that of
course you're going to have people who
are on the other side of it. It's it's
it's a healthy it's a healthy thing. I
know it's hard to kind of think in that
mindset, but that's that's at least my
outlook. Means if if you don't have
people that are naysaying, it's it's
because your goals aren't aren't big
enough. Now, there are going to be
people out there that aren't going to be
fans of you just for whatever reason. It
doesn't matter. Typically, they're
jealous. Typically, they they have some
kind of preconceived notion. They they
gossip about you behind your back. And
we've addressed a lot of these topics in
the podcast and the podcast episodes to
come. But the point here is don't give
somebody a reason to not like you just
because you can. Don't allow them to
change who you are. Don't allow them to
lower your character or your integrity
because of some preconceived notion. And
and here's this other truth. You ready?
Opinions change. There are people that I
used to not like and now I'm like, you
know what? That was kind of dumb of me
back then. I I actually like this person
or vice versa. And it flips. You think
somebody's great and you realize I I got
to know them and
uh kind of empty inside. I don't I don't
agree. This doesn't match and align with
my values anymore. People change. My
guess, if you're listening right now,
there's somebody that you weren't really
a fan of and and then now you're like, I
kind of like this person. It goes the
same thing with siblings. You grew up
with siblings. Like I know two sisters
who hated each other and now they're
like the best of friends. It happens.
Co-workers like I'm not really a fan of
them. At the end you're you're great.
Why? Because time changes things. Always
keep your head above the water. Operate
a frequency that says I'm going to be
true to me regardless of what anybody
else is going to do. So what do you do?
How do you talk to somebody who doesn't
like you? Number one, act like they do.
Treat them like they like you. Talk
exactly like they like you. Why? Because
that is your choice. And you're not
allowing their your p preconceived
notion of what they think about you to
control any of your behavior. Are you
with me? Good. Two. If you can't do
that, keep your emotions in a vacuum.
That means you're going to use neutral,
flat statements that don't do anything
like, "Thanks. Got it. Understood."
That's not the best, but at least it's
going to keep you flat. Number three,
keep all the passive, aggressive,
sarcastic comments at home. Things that
are gonna flare it up. Leave that alone.
Instead, just operate on the facts.
While you're there, what you need to
talk about, get in, get out, get safe.
And keep in mind, opinions always
change.
>> Calm down. You're too sensitive. You're
overreacting. Most of us women have felt
completely invalidated and dismissed by
those words. So, how on earth can we
respond with confidence without losing
our call?
>> If you want to feel confident, then you
have to do assertive things. You have to
assert yourself. Uh confidence is more
of a feeling. Like if I were to say,
hey, I need you to feel scared right
now. You have a hard time doing it
without me being scary. Uh the same
thing to say, I need you to be
confident. You're going to have a hard
time feeling it without doing something
that's going to trigger that. So, it's
the assertive statements that you can
use right into your sentences. So, for
example, if it's that idea of you're
being so sensitive, it's the having the
patience to know, okay, I know I can say
something assertive right here and that
is no, I'm sensing you're being a jerk.
[laughter] You know, if somebody says
it's just a joke, I'm just sensing
you're not that funny. It's that idea of
you flipping their words and having the
wherewithal in that moment to say
something assertive that will then in a
positive feedback loop give you the
feeling of confidence. And then with
that confidence, you want to say more
assertive things.
>> But when someone's being dismissive of
your feelings, if you don't know how to
be assertive, you absolutely may say
something that they can then use to
either weaponize against you. Yeah. Or
they can just then use that same
statement again to prove their point.
>> As in like, see, I told you you're too
sensitive.
>> Right? In those situations with any kind
of personality, they often tease
something up for you to grab. So they
say something ugly. What they're doing
is offering you something and saying,
"Why don't you go ahead and take it? Go
ahead." And once you take it, once you
have that response of that emotional,
uh, I can't believe you. I can't. And
you have that big reaction, now they got
you. you fell for the trap and now all
of a sudden they kind of they take the
joy in that response that you gave that
hit of dopamine that they received from
that control and so now when you react
you are giving away your power but often
it's the silence and the very small
steps that say I'm in control and you
aren't. It's a very it's a a weird
mindset where you have to flip the idea
of when you are sending that zinger
right back at them you're actually
weakening your position not increasing
it.
>> Okay. So, cuz that is exactly what we
do. We we go, "Okay, well, I'm going to
give as good as I'm going to get." And
that feels sometimes in the moment quite
empowering as a woman. It's like, "I've
got my own back. I can stand up for
myself." But to your point, what you end
up doing is weakening your position.
>> So, you say we have one of the best
great secret weapons
>> of pausing.
>> Yes.
>> So, talk to me about in that moment if
you start to feel the heat, you start to
boil, your blood's boiling cuz someone's
being disrespectful to you, they're
dismissing you. take me through the
exact steps of how do you pause,
>> how do you collect your mindset and then
come up with a good response.
>> Yeah. So, what I talk about is
difference between short pauses and long
pauses. And when somebody says something
disrespectful, what you want is a long
pause. That's somewhere between about 5
to 8 seconds. It's just a few seconds of
allowing the other person to hear what
they said. Because let's say you said
something negative to me. Visually one,
it's going to give me the feeling of
confidence when I see that word come and
just fall to the ground and
understanding I don't have to pick that
up.
>> And it's kind of in that silence you're
looking at it going, "Is that is that
what you wanted to say? Does that feel
good? That that right there are you
looking at what I'm looking at?" And
that right there automatically makes
them feel more powerless and you feel
more in control. And that pause, you are
being their echo. You're being their
mirror. So often if somebody were to say
something ugly and I say nothing at all,
often what they do is they they say it
and hear it back in their mind. And
often people might apologize and go, I'm
sorry, I shouldn't have said that or
they rephrase it. Or you can ask the
person a was that supposed to these are
questions of what I call intent. So was
that supposed to hurt me? See how a
question doesn't respond in the way of
sending that zinger back at them. It's a
way of answering without answering.
Did you mean for that to hurt me? Was
that supposed to embarrass me? And you
see how the power is not sending the
zinger to say, I'm going to make you
hurt even worse. The power is when they
throw a punch, you go, that didn't hurt.
So that's that's the control that you
have in that moment.
>> And I assume tone matters cuz even just
the way you said it, it was so calm. I
assume that was supposed to hurt me. Why
did you say that? Versus like, I assume
that was supposed to hurt me. Why did
you say that?
>> Exactly. So take me through how it can
be perceived as you're losing control
versus actually you have control of this
the conversation.
>> Yeah. I mean you can use just what we
did as an example. So if I were to say
you can't talk to me like that. Are you
kidding me? Versus
you cannot talk to me like that. Now
which one sounds more in control?
>> Oh definitely the second.
>> Definitely the second one. And nothing
changes except that you're speaking a
lot slower which shows I'm in control of
my words. And it also shows I'm in
control of my actions because when that
fight or flight kicks in, which you know
all about. You get that emotion. Your
heart starts to beat. You get nervous.
You start to shake. Your voice might
tremble a little bit. You get tears in
your eyes. It's just the emotional
flooding. You're telling your body in
that moment when you're not taking a big
pause and a big breath. You're telling
your body, "I have a lot to fear right
now. I have a lot to be afraid of. So, I
have to be extreme. I have to say that
extreme thing. I have to go all out."
Versus when you slow down and you speak
slowly and even in a lower tone, you're
not only conveying control, you're also
telling your body
this there's nothing to fear here.
>> There's no nothing to threaten me. I'm
safe. And that right there is an
incredibly powerful move uh that you can
flip that script on them to show that
there's nothing here that's that's
threatening me in some way. So that's
what a lot of the pausing does is it
gives a lot of space for them to realize
that what they wanted is not what
they're going to how I see it is when
you say that ugly thing you put it out
on a ledge like you exposed it and
you're hoping you're praying that
somebody will take it. Have you ever
thrown an insult and then they didn't
give it back?
>> Probably.
>> Yeah. And then you go kind of feel like
a jerk later. You realize, oh that
didn't hit. And then you feel kind of
stupid because what you sent out it
didn't get the response. You didn't get
the control and now you feel kind of
silly about it. So that's that's how you
do that. So if I had to break that down,
it'd be one, you want to add about a
five to seven 7se second pause, a long
pause. Two, you want to do it long
enough to make them hear their words
back. And often you can just repeat what
they said back to them. So if you said
something ugly, like you ever said,
"You're an idiot." And I waited five
seconds. I said, "I'm an idiot.
Perfect. Three is you're you're allowing
them to show you can ask questions of
intent. Did you mean for that to
embarrass me? Did you say that to hurt
me or offend me? And uh often times
that's all you really need to do to
realize it's not going to be that fun
for them the second time around.
>> Oh my god, that's so good. And then in
talking about the pause in the power of
it, you also talk about in your book the
power of people forcing you to not
pause. And it's their way almost of
asking your question like rushing you to
answer as a way of them controlling you.
>> Yeah. So in legal depositions, attorneys
do it all the time. We want to get you
responding very quickly. And when you
feel pressured, you often do. A lot of
the clients that I have, I have to train
them on let them get all their question
out, give it a pause, then you say
something because otherwise you want to,
hey, did you go the other day? Yes, I
did. They they they like to cut in
because they just want it over. Same
thing in any argument that you have. You
also want that over because you want the
threat to go away. But where you find
the the moment of control and power for
them is when you can add distance
between what they said and your response
in that distance where you're able to
show them that there's nothing here
that's really going to defeat me in some
way. And so what I like to focus on is
when you are trying to rush your words,
what you're saying them is you're
afraid. Because when you get afraid, you
like to rush your words. And when you
get to slow down, you're in a much
better position almost every single
time. Confident people know they don't
have to say anything. Insecure people
always have something to say, always
have something to add. Insecurities are
loud. Confidence is very quiet. There's
a very big difference in that. people in
your community would want to grasp that
idea of I don't have to say anything
that I don't want to say. Should I not
want to answer that text for 10 minutes?
Maybe I don't want to respond to that
text for the whole day. Then don't. It's
there's no pressure obligation that you
have to send it immediately. You don't
have to send that full paragraph. You
wait. Wait a day. It's going to be a
whole lot better. and you're the one
that's going to feel more controlled and
send the message that you're in more
control of yourself.
>> I love that. I um I often write textes
and I don't send them.
>> Yeah.
>> And I'm like, "All right, if you still
feel like this 24 hours, send it."
>> That's smart.
>> I never end up sending them ever.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
>> Um what I've done is I went deep into my
community and I was looking at all the
things that we women struggle with um
here at Women of Impact and I've pulled
some scenarios for you if you're okay
with helping us through navigating how
we would replace [laughter] our like
sure I don't know what I'm getting
myself into. Okay, so this somewhat
scripts if you will and I realized that
>> in my community maybe you found this
there are two almost different types of
ways of saying things. Number one is a
question, number one is a statement
>> and so they sometimes land differently.
So I would love to hear how you think
through them. So one is um when someone
is just utterly inappropriate
>> to your face. Yeah.
>> Sometimes one of the questions I get all
the time and a lot of women do is, "Why
don't you have kids yet?"
>> Yeah.
>> Sometimes that's very inappropriate. If
you can't have children, that's
heartbreaking of a question. If you've
decided not to, it feels sometimes it's
a challenge to your femininity and your
womanhood. Um, and so when someone asks
that,
>> how would you suggest someone could
reply with confidence? Do you feel like
they have to explain?
>> No. No, I mean part of confidence is the
understanding that you need to stop
justifying everything. You can say no
without justifying it. You can say
anything you want without having to
justify a reason for it. No is, as they
say, a complete sentence. So in that
scenario, if somebody gets asked about,
you know, why aren't you having why have
you had any kids or why don't you have
more kids? Um, one that is an extremely
offensive appropriate question. In that
kind of situation, reading the room, you
could do one of two things. One, you
could ask the question, and I would I
would begin with is it. I like asking
things with is it because it props it up
in in their side of the fence. For
example, is that something you need to
know? Is that something important to
you? Is that something you care about or
is that something you should care about?
So begin your question with is it poses
a question for them that they now have
to respond and most of the time the
answer is going to be no
>> or if you need to turn that into a
statement and it could be something as
that's not something you should know
>> as simple as that. I feel like when it
comes to an inappropriate question the
more inappropriate the more room you
have to turn that question into a a
statement of saying that's that's an
inappropriate question.
>> I love that that's an inappropriate
question. I just that's such a like
straightforward way of responding. Um
but then sometimes it can be a statement
that is offensive but doesn't leave you
really any room. So I'd love to know how
again we get this a lot. Why haven't you
put on weight?
>> Anytime they get questions about
their exterior
um what I like to recommend is that they
own it. Whatever it is they need to love
on themselves. So, whenever somebody
gets a question about weight, their
appearance, my recommendation is for
them to own it to. So, hey, it looks
like you've been put on some weight.
Yeah, I I've been hoping so. I think I
look awesome. I love how I look. It's
just owning it.
>> Yeah. Oh, I love that. It's so hard
though. I was 19 years old and I was
known to be very skinny like as a kid
and then I had blossomed and my body
started to change and I put on weight
and my roommate's mother walked past me
and was like, "Wow, you got so fat."
>> I remember this to that day to this day.
>> Um I've had an unhealthy relationship
with food. A lot of those comments can
not just be a jab. It can be something
that you remember for the rest of your
life and your identity gets built on it.
But sometimes it can be so damn hurtful
that you take it personally. You really
take it to heart.
>> And do you see how even in a little
instance like that, maybe she didn't
mean it, but you took it a lot
differently. And so in that, just that
scenario can prove that it hurts and you
carry it as much as you decide that it
hurts and how much you want to carry.
And so even when you say, "Well, I've
remembered it forever." Well, that
wasn't her choice. It was yours. And so
every time it's that ability to say,
"Okay, well, if I have the choice to
remember this, I also have the choice to
let it go.
>> I'm going to pause for a second
>> because
>> thank you. You metaphorically just
slapped me around the face and I love
it." [laughter]
>> And I I really mean that. Like I I I
think sometimes wakeup calls are great.
>> Um I'm such a person of growth and
evolution and it's clearly something
that has stuck with me because I just
said it on this show, right? I mean,
this was when I was 18. And so, thank
you for being that honest. I always want
that hard truth, even if it's hard to
hear. So, putting the onus on me
>> is a beautiful gift you've just given
me. Thank you for that.
>> Yeah, of course.
>> Still got a few more though. Ready?
Let's [laughter] keep going.
>> What about deflecting blame with sarcasm
as a example? Sorry, I guess I just
can't do anything right.
>> Yeah. When you want to handle a passive
aggressive comment, often what I like to
say is you need to start your response
with sounds like or seems like. Sounds
like there's more to that.
Chris Voss has an awesome line that I
love and it says seems like you had a
reason for saying that.
>> Sounds like you have a reason for saying
that. It just kind of calls them out of,
hey, you're not you're not coming out of
the gate. You're not being uh open with
this. And uh I like Sounds like there's
more to that. That's probably one of my
favorite go-tos is sounds like there's
more to that because they'll they'll
share almost always. Another one that I
like to um use with passive aggressive
people is should I read into that?
>> I do that a lot with texts.
>> Oh,
>> should I read into that? And almost
every time you'll get a very clear
answer of, "Oh, no, no, no, no. I just I
I was just texting and I know I was
reading the context in it, but often
it's should I read into that? that
shortness that uh it's a weird word that
you threw in there.
>> But going to what you just said that
most people go, "Oh no, no, no, no, no."
Yeah,
>> that's all I most of the time I assume
that's BS. They actually do mean
something
>> sometimes. Yes. But the but that the
point is you called it out,
>> right? Okay. So So the fact that they're
backing off, you don't then proceed. You
just back off as well, do you? I go
actually a little harder recently. So
passive aggressiveness for me was such a
trigger cuz I was like, I don't know how
like it feels like they're insinuating
something but not quite saying it. And
then if I bring it up, I used to be then
say, "Oh, you're being paranoid." Like
it's all you and so the blame keeps
coming back to you. So then that makes
you not speak up when someone's being
passive aggressive. I realize that
doesn't help. I feel like that is a bit
of a bullying technique.
>> Um and so I started to call people on it
by saying like, "What do you mean by
that statement?"
>> Yes.
>> And then they would back off and I'm
like, "But what did you mean?" Like no,
no, no, no. But what did you actually
mean?
>> Yeah. you like to take it further
>> only because I have noticed and I would
love you're the professional so I want
to know your opinion but only because I
noticed it doesn't eliminate the problem
they're just going to be snide and
passive aggressive in a different way
next time. So do you advise to not then
keep going?
>> Yeah, depends. I mean, I think that um I
like to view it as if there's like a two
negatives of a magnet like I'm I'm just
showing you right now when I say
something like um it sounds like there's
more to that and you kind of go away and
then me said no no really you go ahead
and tell me what did you mean by that?
What did you mean [laughter] by that?
When I I mean now I'm starting to now
I'm starting to come on. uh when they
said something passive aggressive for a
reason, it just wasn't didn't feel
comfortable to them. And you pressing
more more is not going to make them feel
more comfortable. And what you want is
them to open up, not clam up. And so
often you you could even use it as
sounds like there's something for us to
talk about.
>> Um for example, we talked about in text,
somebody sends a text and didn't make
sense to you and you you decided it was
a rude text. If you even responded, did
you mean for that to sound rude? Did you
mean for that to sound short? I use that
a lot. Did you mean for that to sound
short? They go, "No, no, no. I didn't
mean that." Let's say they did, like you
said, they really did want that to sound
short. And then you start to press, "No,
no. I want to know like, so what did you
really mean by it? If you didn't say
that, what did you mean?"
>> It's it's going to make them feel like
they're backed into a corner. And nobody
backed into to a corner wants to open up
more. It's it's going to fight or
flight. Often, it's much better to say,
"Okay, mental note. Let me bring this up
at a time that we can talk and have real
space and dialogue on it.
>> That's so good. It didn't really feel
right in my body when I was doing it,
but it definitely felt like I was um
having my own back. I'm such a goal
oriented person. It's like what am I
trying to get to? What's the goal? And
then how do I get there? And you talk
about that a lot in your book. It's like
know the goal of the conversation first.
How often do we not know the goal and we
just go into something and then when we
leave the conversation, we never
actually end up getting what we want.
>> Exactly. I I'll even give you a sentence
that I've used many many times and
you're going to love the next time this
happens
>> is you're going to respond, I love to
talk about it.
>> And what you're saying is no, this topic
right here, let's keep let's keep going
on it. And that's passive aggressive
people don't like that because they're
getting called out, but if you were to
even respond, I'd like to talk more
about it. Happy to talk more about it.
What you're sending is two things. One,
I'm addressing what you're saying
without responding to the passive
aggressiveness. And the other side is
I'm showing you here that we have an
open window to actually have some
dialogue that it's going to be their
decision to walk through that door or
not. If there's one thing that I
personally struggle with, it's feeling
defensive. It's natural, but it's also
the number one killer of conversation.
If you feel defensive, you shut
everybody off. And if they feel
defensive, they're not going to listen
to anything else you have to say. On
today's episode, it's all about how do
you handle defensiveness? If there's one
thing about defensiveness,
it's that it's so easy to do. It's just
biological. It's natural because
anything that you perceive as a threat
or a challenge, you fight against. It is
natural as part of your fight or flight.
On any argument that you're going to
have, there are two sides. There is an
ignition side and a cooling side of it.
And that ignition is triggered by things
that trigger you. So anytime somebody
challenges your opinion or disagrees
with you, your body perceives that as a
threat that says, "I don't like that."
Somebody gives you an opinion and you
disagree, your body says, "I don't like
that." Somebody's telling you what to
do, your body goes, I don't really like
that. So every time that happens, there
is a desire to push back against it. If
somebody's telling you you need to go do
this, you automatically want to go, "No,
I don't." If somebody says, "Well, you
were behaving this way last night. You
were in a bad mood last night." You
automatically want to go, "No, I
wasn't." Who are you to tell me how I
was or how I'm feeling or what to do? We
preserve that element of autonomy within
ourselves. And so anytime you feel
defensiveness, it is just so reactionary
and it's nearly impossible to stop from
the get-go. But there are some tips and
techniques that I'm going to give you to
make sure that you know how to handle it
in the moment. Number one, to keep
yourself from getting defensive. Let
their words fall to the ground. This is
what I mean. In case you forgot, other
people's words are not your
responsibility to carry. It's not tennis
or volleyball. You don't have to throw
anything back. So instead, you're just
going to take a breath, imagine that
their words fall to the ground, and you
get to decide whether to pick them up or
just leave them there. And you're going
to find more often than not, you just
want to leave them there. Number two,
get rid of beginning your sentence with
you. When it comes to responding in an
argument, the word you is very
triggering because it's you telling them
what to do, how they should behave, what
they need to say, what they need to do,
and they're going to get defensive. So
instead of you, we're going to tweak
that to start with I. When you start
with I, it's not nearly as triggering.
Number three, you're going to use
phrases that help dampen defensive
responses. Responses like, I agree,
that's something that we should
consider. Or, that's helpful for me to
know. Thank you. When you use those
phrases, it's telling them that they're
getting acknowledged and they're not
going to get defensive. What I try to do
when somebody tells me something and I
can tell that I'm getting defensive, I
try and imagine like what they just told
me was a piano note. All right? You ever
heard somebody just hit one key on the
piano and they just leave their finger
there and you just let that note sustain
is what they call it. You let that note
just end by itself to where it
eventually just falls. It drops. The
note is no longer heard. it. That's how
I imagine it. So, when somebody says
something that I don't like, instead of
having this very reactionary response,
this very defensive response that I know
is not worth my energy and time, I
picture in my mind that it has fallen.
The the word just fell out of their
mouth and they're on the ground. And I
get to look at them and go, "Is this
worth my time? Is this worth my energy?"
often when I start to get involved in it
and I start to pick it up, I tell myself
this phrase, what I use, small talks,
and that is I tell myself, "Put it down,
Jefferson. Put it down, Jefferson. It's
not worth your time. What are you doing?
Put it down." I I say those things to
myself and it helps me. It controls my
emotions when I can inject my breath,
let my breath be the first thing that I
say, and have that slow reaction and go,
you know what? No, I don't have to send
that back. I don't have to hit that back
over the net. I don't have to take a
swing at this. Just let it go by.
There's there's not an umpire. Just let
them have a bad pitch. They threw a
ball. So what? You don't swing at them.
You don't swing at those. So when I have
that kind of mentality, it it helps me
in a very specific way because defensive
behavior is just biological. It is in
innate within every one of us that we
naturally want to defend things. We want
to defend uh our intelligence. We want
to um defend our credibility. We want to
defend our own ideas and opinions. And
when somebody is conflicting with those,
we want to put our wall up, to put our
shield up to protect that. That's why so
often when you start to say things and
you can tell somebody's fighting and
fighting and fighting, they are
defending against their own ideas. They
are protecting their house, so to speak.
That's why that whole idea of having
something to learn instead of something
to prove, having something that's open
rather than something that's pointing at
them is going to open up the dialogue so
much better and not going to have these
defensive reactions. So, anytime that
somebody tells you something and you
start to feel that tension in your body
that's preparing you for that fight or
flight, just imagine that their words
are falling to the ground. You're going
to take a few seconds and decide for
yourself, is this something I need to
respond to? And in truth, it's a cycle,
what I call a self-fulfilling prophecy.
If I say something and they get
defensive, well, more often than not,
they're going to say something back and
then I'm going to get defensive and all
of a sudden we're just saying things
that are hurting each other. We both
have our walls up. When it comes to
defensive behavior, one of the worst
things you can do is begin your sentence
with you. If I were to tell you right
now, you seem like you're in a bad mood.
Or if I were just to be very blunt,
you're in a bad mood.
Most likely you're going to disagree
with me or you're going to correct me or
you're going to adjust what I just told
you. You're going to say, "No, no, I'm
not." Or, "Well, no, I'm just I'm
irritated right now." You're not going
to accept that I said you're in a bad
mood because you is assump
assumptionbased. It is trying to tell
somebody what they're doing, what they
need to be doing. Uh, you're not
listening to me. It gets people
defensive because what they want to say
is, "Yes, I am. I am listening to you
versus me saying I feel like you're not
listening to me. I feel like I'm not
being heard. When you change you to I,
it's not nearly as defensive because I'm
not assuming that you're doing anything.
If I were to say you don't even care.
You don't care. Automatically you're
going to what you're thinking inside is
yes, I am. I I do care. People don't
like to be told that they are something
or they feel a certain way or they're
doing something. We don't like that. So,
when you just easily turn it from
instead of begin your sentence with you,
change it to I, change it to I. It's
just it's that easy. I I can't make it
any more simple than that. When
somebody's getting defensive,
the most likely culprit is because you
started a sentence with you. I'm also
guilty of that. All right. Anytime that
somebody's getting in defensive in an
argument with me or a conversation, I
can go back in my mind and go, I I
started that sentence with you. I
shouldn't have done that. When I
rephrase it with an I and say, "Hey, can
I can I start over?" I feel like I I
wasn't heard. I'm beginning with I. And
it's going to smooth it out a whole lot
better. So, easiest transition here is
anytime you say something to keep
somebody from getting defensive, instead
of you, just replace it with I instead
of you can't talk to me like that. It's
I don't respond to that volume. I don't
respond to that tone. You make it about
you yourself as a saying, I I feel this
way and take it away from that other
person and they're not going to get
defensive. Now, I also want to make sure
that I equip you with some phrases that
are going to help dampen defensive
behavior. If you're already in that
argument and things are already going
and you go, "Oh man, I I really need to
just calm things down for a second."
Here are some phrases that I want you to
use real quick. One of my favorites is
beginning your sentence with I agree.
Now, listen to me. I'm not saying that
you're agreeing with what they said. All
right? Instead, you're just agreeing
that the discussion needs to be had.
Instead of thinking micro, go macro. So,
if somebody's communicating, instead of
saying getting all defensive and arguing
with them, I can just say, "I agree that
this is worth discussing." You feel
automatically that's just going to
settle the conversation. It's going to
smooth it out. They're going to lower
their voice, lower their tone. The
spikes are going to be as pointy. Just
say, "Hey, I I agree. We need to talk
about this." Simple as that. Begin your
sentence with, "I agree. I agree that
this subject is worth discussing." You
hear how different that is? They're
going to feel acknowledged like, "Okay,
this is I I'm not having to fight. I
don't have to fight and put put up all
the spikes all the time." Another that I
like to use is that's helpful to know.
Tell them that they've been helpful. And
when somebody feels like they've been
helpful, it feels like they're involved
in their own mutual understanding that
they have helped uh teach you things.
That's why I also like using the phrase
what I've learned by listening to you
right now. I've I've learned I have some
work to do or I've learned that this
topic is really important to you. That's
one I've used often. I've learned that
this topic is is important to you. just
by them hearing I've learned, they feel
like they've taught something and it's
going to lower it's going to lower all
the walls because now they feel like
they're on the same playing field. They
don't have to continue to pick up their
sword and fight and cut and slash to
defend their property, defend their own
ideas and opinions. Instead, when you
use these phrases like, "I agree this is
worth talking about or that's helpful
for me to know or I've I've learned that
this is important to you." Those are all
going to quickly put out a lot of fires
for you.
>> What if you're with somebody who
I used it earlier, but I want to go a
little bit deeper. They pick on you.
They kind of gnaw at you a little bit.
You know, everything is almost um
passive aggressive in the way they say
things and you find yourself
almost being put down subtly when you
communicate with this person. And I find
this an awful lot lately with couples
that are friends of mine, married
couples. There's this subtle dynamic
where they both are a little bit passive
aggressive with one another and the way
they communicate and I I feel empathy
for the one that I think is the one
receiving most of the aggression. Is
there something you can do when you feel
like someone's communicating with you
that way? Is there a phraseiology or a
or a strategy for that?
>> Let's separate into two different
categories. So, one, let's say, is kind
of this more uh just passive aggressive
bucket. The other is let's ramp it up to
somebody being a little bit more overtly
disrespectful,
rude. So, in this first bucket, this
passive aggressive, these are people
that most likely just have grown up that
way. This is what they saw mirrored uh
conversation and arguments throughout
their life and they don't know how to
express that kind of thing. So when they
slide in that negative comment that you
know there's something to that a simple
question of like should I read into that
or is there more to that or I and this
goes for Chris Foss a dear friend and he
I love his his question is sounds like
you have a reason for saying that. I
love that phrase. I I also love sounds
like there's more to that. So, anytime
you can just quickly ask, "Sounds like
there's more to that or ask them,"
should I read into that? That tends to
draw out the passive aggressiveness
because they're not expecting you to
kind of call them to the floor. On the
flip side, if somebody is saying more
aggressive things towards you, my
recommendation is begin your question
with, "Did you mean did you mean for
that to sound rude? Did you say that to
embarrass me? Did you say that to hurt
my feelings?
uh did you say that to offend me? It
when you say did you mean it is twofold.
One, it's giving them the grace of
perhaps they said it in a way they did
not mean and it's going to allow them to
fix it. Like uh at least with me and my
wife, if we're texting and something
seems like it's off, instead of it
saying, you know, why are you being so
short? What's wrong?
>> Yeah. Yeah. the question. I ask the
question, did you mean for that to sound
short?
>> Instantly, almost every time
>> my, you know, it is like the, "Oh, no,
no, no, no. Sorry. I'm picking up the
kids or I, you know, I was checking out
the grocery store. I getting gas."
>> You know, you you get that that K or
okay, and you're like, "Oh, okay. I
guess I guess they hate me right now."
All right. Like, I guess they're in a
mood. And then you naturally get in a
mood. And then you respond defensively,
which causes them to respond
offensively. And now you're convinced.
you've convinced yourself you're under
attack. So, it's this um this feedback
loop that's not helpful to you. So, when
you begin with did you mean it's a great
way to set somebody to one give them
that grace of fixing it, but two, it's
calling attention to what they were
wanting to do. Did you say that to to
embarrass me? Did you say that to to
offend me? It is uh or did you mean for
that to sound rude? like that is a very
quick way to address it out in the open
and if they're going to double down on
it or not.
>> Will you do that in re by the way, this
is so good. Will you do that in reverse
if you feel that what you've said has
been misinterpreted? In other words, if
you feel like you're I do this better in
business than I do personal life to be
honest with you. In personal life, I
think I just let everything out the
window that I know that are tools, which
is so stupid. When it comes to business,
I'm pretty good at this. with friends
and family, I devolve into the most
emotionally immature person sometimes.
But so let's say we have gone back and
forth and maybe I've said something
the other way that they're hurt by. Will
you slow a conversation down, for
example, and say something like, "What
did you hear me say?" How will you
handle that if the person is now coming
back at you for something they believe
you said that's passive aggressive or
demeaning or rude?
>> Awesome question. This happens all the
time, especially in relationships, but
I'd say even wor too, when somebody
tells you something. You've been in that
situation where somebody is going,
"That's not what you said. You said
this." And they kind of give a voice
that doesn't even sound like your voice
and gives a
>> intonation and and you're like, "I
didn't even say it like that." And all
of a sudden now you're going, "That's
not what I said. I didn't say it like
that." You're just pushing what you
thought you conveyed. And nine times out
of ten it is inaccurate because what is
said is not always what's received. So
instead of this that's not what I said.
Um you are going to ask the question
what did you hear? What did you hear?
Because now it's not about what I am
putting out. I am now getting curious of
what you heard because that's what
matters. anytime you had that kind of
confrontation or that miscommunication
instead of going, "No, no, no, no,
that's not what that's not what I said."
And kind of dismissing their whole
experience or their perspective. Uh, by
the way, it's very hard to to judge.
It's like making your own movie but not
having an audience and going, "No, no,
that's not how the movie goes." It's
like nobody else has seen it. Only
you're the one who thinks it's that way.
So, when you ask the question, "What did
you hear?" and they explain it, that's
when you can say, "That was not my
intent." or I apologize for that
impression. Or I would recommend is
begin your sentence with I can see like
I can see how you'd feel that way. I can
see how that come off.
>> You know, whenever you say um you know I
I can see why you'd feel that way. I can
see why uh that would upset you. That I
can see just says, hey, I took a second
to walk over to where you're standing
and I turn to look the same way that
you're looking and I can confirm. Yeah.
What you see is reasonable. What you see
is justified. You know what? That makes
sense. I can see that. That right there
just goes. It naturally takes down the
aggression. This I have to win. You have
to see it what I see. Anytime you can do
that and use words of perspective, uh
like view, perspective, see. Um that is
going to help somebody go, "Oh, I feel
heard. Oh, I feel understood." And by
that, they're going to be more receptive
to the progress. If you want to change
your life for the better, well, this is
one of the best ways to do it. On
today's episode, we're talking how to
respond with confidence. If you want to
sound more confident, do this. Number
one, eliminate the fluff. Eliminate the
fluff. You know what I'm talking about.
Fluff is that kind of Well, I mean, you
know, it's it's just this um it's just
this I mean, you know, it's it's um uh
fluff. Fluff that absolutely kills the
confidence in your responses. Number
two, we're going to work on uptalk. That
is where you begin to increase in the
tone of your voice. Almost like you're
asking a question. Instead of saying
something like this, it sounds kind of
like this. At the end of your sentences,
they uptalk. And that's not good because
it makes it sound like everything you're
saying is a question, like you're
uncertain about it. And number three,
we're going to work on word choice. That
means we're going to eliminate ending
your sentences with, you know what I
mean? We're going to eliminate using the
word just all the time and we're going
to minimize your reliance on adverbs.
Those are words that end in ly.
Literally. Now, I want to be clear.
There is a difference between talking to
friends and talking in a professional
setting. Period. When you're talking to
people that are close to you, who cares
about fluff words? If you are fumbling
over your words and you're saying um and
you know and uh I mean well maybe you
know anytime you're saying that to a
friend, no problem. It's casual. It's
comfortable. It's part of the
conversation. But if you're talking in a
professional setting, maybe at work,
maybe in front of uh an important group,
do you hear I just said that? in uh an
important group, then it's not that not
great for you because it makes it sound
as if you are uncertain, like you're
hesitant, like you're not sure what
you're wanting to say. But in regular
conversation, it's it's part of the
game. Now, about fluff, fluff comes in
all shapes and sizes, and I want you to
think about it as if it is static. It's
a filler. They call them filler words. I
like to say fluff. Um, they also are
ways of thinking about it of too much
ice in your drink because they dilute
your message. If you want to sound
confident, you got to serve your words
straight. So, when you begin a sentence
in front of a group, they ask you a
question and it's you're on the spot to
respond and the first thing out of your
mouth is um, that's very common. They
ask you a question and the first thing
you want to say is um
uh well uh automatically that confidence
and how you sound just tinks because
you're not communicating. You're just
wanting to make sound out. That's really
what it is. We feel comfortable when
we're have this constant soundwave.
Whenever there's the constant just
noise, whether it's actual words being
articulated or not, we just like hearing
that that sound. So that's why it comes
out that way. if they somebody askked me
a question and I go um you know well I
mean it it it depends you you know you
see how vague that is versus you ask me
a question and the first thing uh that I
say is I haven't run across that before
I think it depends on a number of
factors and I begin to speak very
different same goal I'm telling them
I've never run across that before very
different sound so you want to find ways
to eliminate that fluff and how you do
It is very simple. It's very simple.
Okay, enough. It's so simple. You're
going to be like, Jefferson, I I knew
this. But are you doing it? The question
here is, do you know how to eliminate
that fluff? And you do it by saying
nothing. Wherever the fluff would be,
just get used to silence.
It's that easy. Get comfortable with
silence. That's it. You just get
comfortable with silence. So, wherever
that filler word would be, say nothing.
The way I teach, and I know I've said
this on my podcast before, let your
breath be the first word that you say.
So, when somebody asks you a question
that you don't know, the worst thing you
can do is go um and look up as if you're
searching for the words. Instead, take a
breath, let that silence be there, and
then you get to respond. You don't have
to have just noise for the sake of
noise. Give it a pause and fill that
space with absolute nothing. allow your
breath to catch the attention for them
to hang on to your next words for you to
say I haven't run across that before but
what I am confident about is we can look
at X Y and Z that's how you handle fluff
now upt talk is a little bit different
and I find that it is very
dependent on gender most of the time or
men don't really have this issue but
women do it's a it's an uptalk uh just
because of the way you can tweak the end
and sound of your voice, but it
certainly happens to to guys, too. I
don't want to say it's just a female
thing or a male thing at all. It's not.
But it it sounds like this when you have
that people who are in the office and
they're talking to you and they go,
"Yeah, I think I can do that. I mean,
yeah, we can probably get it to you by
Friday." Like as if you're hanging on to
as if they're asking for permission in
some way. When you say that and you
sound like that, it cuts down on your
confidence because it sounds like you're
not sure. that sounds like you're
unclear and you're asking for permission
in some way. Think of it this way. This
is how I want you to say your words. Ask
as if you're asking someone to pass the
salt. All right? Here over in America,
in Texas, if I'm going to ask somebody
to pass the salt, I'm going to say,
"Hey, so and so, can you pass the salt?"
Period. You see how my my volume, excuse
me, my my tone there at the the end went
down? Can you pass the salt? So when you
end on a lower note, it sounds more
serious. You see that? And instead of
saying it sounds more serious, it sounds
more serious. When you uptalk, it sounds
like you're asking a question. When you
go down, it sounds like you're making a
firm statement. So I wouldn't say, "Hey,
can you pass the salt?" as if I don't
know what salt is or you don't know what
salt is. Instead, I say, "Can you pass
the salt?" as if I'm assuming, "Yes,
everybody knows what it is. I'm going to
keep that that cadence flat. And if I
can drop the tone just a little bit at
the bottom to make it sound a lot more
firm and a lot more confident. All
right, this one is uh this one's going
to step on some toes a little bit. This
is word choice. Word choice. What are
the words that you're saying to sound
confident at any given time? One of the
biggest culprits in my view is ending
your sentence with something that
doesn't feel burn. Does that make sense?
There it is. right there. This element
of does that make sense? Every time you
ask that question, you're doing
something that is double-sided. Let me
explain. If I'm going to tell you
something and I make a statement, I say,
"Does that make sense?" I'm doing two
things. The reason I'm saying that,
reason you may be saying that is because
it's this internal fear or insecurity of
maybe the words that I'm saying aren't
actually making sense to someone.
They're not clear. I'm not I'm not
communicating well. On the other side,
I'm assuming that what I am saying may
or may not be making sense to them. So
the other person it could also be
offensive in some way to them especially
if you make it after a statement that is
very common like I mean the sky is blue
today. Does that make sense? The other
person's like oh yeah of course of
course it makes sense. Yeah. Yeah it
makes sense. You just it was a plain
sentence. There's nothing complicated
about that. So in some ways you may be
insulting their intelligence by saying
does that make sense? You you poor
pitiful mind. you does does that do I
need to go a little bit slower for you?
So, I'm not saying it's all the time,
but it definitely runs that risk. I've
certainly had it where somebody asks,
"Does that make sense?" after a
statement where I only say, "Yes, yes,
that that makes sense. How how else
could I have taken that sentence?" But I
know where it's coming from is this
insecurity feeling of am I saying it
right? Am I doing okay? It's best that
you eliminate that. All right? Instead
of saying, "Does that make sense?" You
can replace that with what are your
thoughts? That's it. What are your
thoughts? Do you have any questions? Do
you have any feedback? My favorite is
what are your thoughts? Instead of,
"Does that make sense?" I'm saying,
"What are your thoughts?" I'm inviting
communication. I'm inviting continuing
the conversation instead of, "Do we need
to stop and set a new paragraph for you
to feel comfortable with this?" I'm
inviting them. What are your thoughts?
What do you think? That's it. They might
say, "I'm I'm good. I don't have any
thoughts. That sounds great. Awesome.
But at least I'm not assuming that they
didn't understand what I said if I said,
"Does that make sense?" So, I would get
rid of that. Just replace it with what
are your thoughts. Another way to tweak
some of your communication to sound more
confident is eliminate the word just. I
love the word just in my regular day
conversation. It's very common. But if
I'm going to communicate in front of a
group, try to eliminate it. Or if you're
going to email somebody, try to
eliminate it. Hear the difference. If I
text you or email or I say to you, "Hey,
uh, I just wanted to check in. I just
want to touch base." That sounds almost
hesitant, doesn't it? Hey, just want to
check in. That sounds almost hesitant
versus, "Hey, I wanted to check in on
you. I wanted to touch base. That sounds
like I'm leaning into it. I'm not shying
away. I'm stepping into it. I wanted to
do this versus hey, I I just wanted to
as if I'm just a little bit don't I'm
not trying to get in your space. Very
different. Eliminate that word just
because it makes you sound more hesitant
in your communication and and that's
that's not the way you you want to
sound. Another is the way you use
adverbs. I'm going to step on a little
bit of toes here with with this. And
that is often when you overuse adverbs,
it makes it more fluffy to where they're
really not saying anything. We all have
these little ticks that we like to say.
Maybe we got them from family. Maybe we
got them from friends or where wherever
you're working, but they cut down on the
confidence and assertiveness of your
sentences. So, here's some words like
that. Essentially, big culprit.
Literally those two alone basically
anything that ends with l y here is a
very common response when somebody is
responding to something or a answering a
question that you're asking they're
going to say. So essentially I mean what
we have is that means nothing. That
means nothing. It's just it's just
fluff. Those are comfort words. Those
are security blankets that you like to
have. It's going to be best if you
eliminate those. There's not some kind
of cure. You just need to find ways to
get rid of them. If you ever see an
email that says essentially or basically
or literally or any other type of words,
understand you can just eliminate them
and they're going to be a whole lot
better. Remember, if you want to have
strong sentences, you need to just serve
your words straight every time. If you
enjoyed that clip and want to see the
rest of the conversation, you can click
right here. Or if you want to see the
latest episode of the Jefferson Fisher
Podcast, click right here and I'll meet
you there.